hi George Herbert Walker Bush it was the
pinnacle of his political career his
inauguration as president in 1989 I'll
help meager in graduation by his side
Barbara the love of his life
and what a life long eventful and
remarkable in so many ways born in the
optimistic America of the 20s he was
raised in a large affluent family his
father a senator passing on a tradition
of public service at 18 he was the
Navy's youngest fighter pilot in the
Second World War flying combat missions
in the South Pacific including one where
he had to be rescued by a u.s. submarine
in shark-infested waters after being hit
by Japanese anti-aircraft fire he went
into the oil business
it made him a millionaire and a
political career beckoned first standing
for Congress strengthened the United
Nations and later becoming US ambassador
to the United Nations and also director
of the CIA after two terms as vice
president to Ronald Reagan he campaigned
for the top job with a famous mantra
read my lips
his promise not to raise taxes backfired
when having won the presidency who did
just that
but his term was dominated by world
events the fall of the Berlin Wall the
collapse of the Soviet Union and most
memorably war in the Gulf as I report to
you air attacks are underway against
military targets in Iraq Operation
Desert Storm followed the invasion of
Kuwait by Iraqi forces in 1990 air
strikes and a ground attack to remove
Saddam's forces from Kuwait led to the
surrender of many Iraqi troops and a
ceasefire within weeks Bush was later
criticized for not pushing on to Baghdad
to remove Saddam from power he felt it
would cost too many lives the decision
seemed popular at the time but the
economy fell into recession and Bush
paid the price when challenged by Bill
Clinton in 1992 an independent Ross
Perot also took votes from Bush
he maintained an active life even
skydiving regularly to mark special
birthdays and he pursued his love of
sports usually with Barbara right
alongside but gradually his health
declined and he developed a form of
Parkinson's disease when Barbara died it
took quite a toll and ended the longest
marriage of any presidential couple in
US history 73 years her funeral attended
by former presidents and their wives
George HW Bush was also the longest
living president in American history it
was an extraordinary life mark Osteen
Sky News